bem vindos a mais um vídeo e hoje vou
ensinar como fazer um arco e flecha uma
pistola que para um latido que os
responsáveis tiveram muito na moda até
agora mas ainda estou à venda por todo
lado então é bastante fácil de encontrar
e só se juntarem o arco e e pistola vão
ter um minimalista estarão bastante
pequenina mas ainda tem alguma força por
isso vocês fizerem têm que usar óculos
de proteção
como podem ver que eu tenho duas canetas
3d mas utilizo mais destaque azul porque
o filamento é mais barato para fazer o
arco vocês têm que assinar uma folha
quadriculada de forma que fique
simétrico e depois é só preencher com a
caneta 3d e uma coisa muito importante é
o filamento estou usar o filamento pl a
existe o abs e obl a para finalizar é só
pôr fim no arco
convém que o filho seja um pouco mais
grosso para ser mais fácil por disparar
flechas corta em um gesto e para flashes
eu utilizei pedacinhos de esgotadas as
potências disputada mas para que as
coisas se repetem melhor vocês têm por
um pouco de peso na parte da frente para
fazer pistola como não tenho uma
impressora o que eu fui fazer é foi
pesquisar na internet com solas usa
folha por cima do ecrã e desenhei a
volta e depois vocês é só fazer como
estou vendo vídeo com preenchendo o
molde mas é importante que vocês design
pistola dos dois lados seja anulado vir
uma folha ao contrário e design do outro
lado porque vocês conseguem ver se
desenharem com força do lado combinaria
contrário dá pra ver essas marcas só que
aí também de um povo estado ou dois não
tiveram tem problema podem usar sempre
um pedaço de cartão o usuário que
incluir em cola pode usar uma cola
qualquer para ficar mais bonito você
está em conquistar isto vai ficar sem
tudo preto
aí uma coisa estou fazendo este vídeo
porque vocês é comentaram bastante criou
mais no último vídeo da caneta 3d e por
isso também estou a pensar fazer um que
voltei de uma caneta ou mais no canal
estou a falar com uma empresa mas não
der certo não tem problema eu vou
comprar e fazer o gol inimigo
e para finalizar é só incorporar o arco
na pistola e depois deste vídeo vou
fazer um vídeo é mostrar o meu quarto e
os equipamentos que utilizo para gravar
vejam que aquela maneira mais simples de
parar mas se vocês quiserem podem fazer
um corte em caixa o fio e eu ficava
preso e quando caem com o dedo de para a
flecha e só chegamos enfim muito
obrigado tecido até a próxima